e
herkese merhaba
heyecanlıyız biraz
Sizlerde cansız Ben de biraz
heyecanlıyım
da 22 yıl önce
Babamlara böyle bir arayıp dedim ki
tiyatro çıkacağım kaç yılda bir olur şu
anda kırkçeşme yaklaştım Bu arada
çıkın gelin
tabii zorla getirdim Bizimkileri sonra
her sene bir tiyatroydu maalesef
hepsine gelmediler ama
bugün de tek konuşması var dedim kırk
yılda bir
ve çekin gelin dedim Sağ olsunlar yerler
öreceğim bu
[Müzik]
bir tanem ben çekildim
Sizce baktım böyle Gözlerim doldurdum
rağmen yapmaya çalışıyorum ama sırada da
kız kardeşim ufak Tabii anne abim
ağlıyor iyice Ben
yenmekle
ağlamak arasında gidip geliyorsun 600
kişi izliyor ve bayağı zorlanmış tık
sonra heyecanımızı attık şu anda
Sizlerde heyecanınızı atmışsınız Ben de
attıysam bir şekilde başlayacağım bugün
ailem dışında
sağımızda burada için teşekkür ediyorum
da
başlıyorum sonra değişti adam stres
yapıyorum
Benim konu başlığım
hayatta en büyük risk hiç ayağı kurmama
ne yapıyor musunuz işte hayatta en büyük
riski hiç risk almamaktır Evet al bu
genelde içinde bunu bize çok anladılar
ve ve gerçekten risk almanın önemini hep
biliriz Ama bu hayattaki en büyük Işık
Bana göre hiç hayal kurmalı ayağı
kurduğumuz zaman Çünkü şeylere ulaşmak
için başarılı olabiliyoruz onu
başlığımız beyaz
bulaştığını görüyorsunuz
çocuklar çok hayal kurarlar
çocukken sonra
ayarlar aileleri tarafından ya abartılı
bulmuş Ya da boş ver sen onu Ne
yapacaksın yapamazsın gibi mesela oyuncu
olmak istiyordur
çırpılmış Çocuk
çocukların hayallerine bir şekilde
büyükler işte imkansız yapamazsın diye
diye
öğretirler ve zamanla bu çocuklar
büyüdüklerinde hayal kurmaktan
vazgeçerler
hayal kurmaktan Vazgeçti Her zaman da
maalesef
o günü kurtaran çocuklara ve nesillere
dönüşünü O yüzden
çocuklarınızın Hayal kurmasına
burada karşınıza ne kadar
olduğu birçok hayalini gerçekleştirmiş
ve yeni ayarlar Kur'an olarak çıktım her
zaman rol model aldığı kişiler vardır
Bunlardan birisi de ağaçta indir ve
onun sözleri
ama bana göre Nestle eşit tuttu tabi
Sadece o değil birçok bilim adamı ve
Bunları hep kendimize rol model
almalıyız ve bro modellerle kendimize
geliştirmeliyiz
bu Hedef olan insana Belki bir şekilde
yardımcı olacak Ama hayal kurmayan insan
sadece a noktasından B noktasına
gidecektir Ama hayal kuran insan her
yere gidebilir şimdi ben burada teorik
bilgi veriyorum ama biz Okulda da ya da
Üniversitede ders anlatırken de teorik
anlattığımız zaman çok anlaşılmıyor O
yüzden kendi hayatından örnekler vererek
pratikte bunun nasıl olduğunu size
ispatlamak istiyorum Yani gerçekten
hayal kurduğumuz zaman
be istediğimiz zaman ve çok çalıştığımız
zaman gerçekten bir yerlere gelebiliyor
muyuz başarabiliyor muyuz buna bir
bakalım
Tabii ki böyle başlamadan şunu da söyle
yani
bu Hayal kurmak sadece yetmeyecek
bu hayal kurduğumuz zaman bizim bir el
çantamız olacak ya da bir sırt çantasını
isterseniz o hayale ulaşmak için yeterli
bi özveriye sahip miyiz Çok çalışacak
mıyız bu hedefe gerçekten inanıyor muyuz
istiyor muyuz Bunların hepsi çok önemli
öyle kuru kuruya kurmakta değil bizim
kişi ve
şimdi bir
böyle anlamsız bir şekilde görüyorsunuz
benim sahipler genelde böyledir Hatta
benim asistanlar var işte ders
anlatacakları zaman slaytları veriyorum
abi de bir tane şekil koymuşsun bir saat
konuşuyorsun Ben de anlatacağım burada
değil misin ya böyle böyle yani burada
toplamda bütün suyu boyunca göreceğiniz
5 slayt var
Şimdi ters teklifi nedir bilir misiniz
Ben çok severim tensegrity bilen var mı
bu erginlik ve denge ya gerginlik ve
bütünlük yani çubuklar böyle üst üste
gelir çocukların oyuncakları vardır
dengeyi sağlamak için tensegrity ben çok
severim derslerde vücut bütünlüğünü
anlatırken ağrıyı anlatırken tüm
kullanırım
hayatımızda tanıdığımız herkes
Yaptığımız her bir iş aldığımız her bir
eğitim yaşadığımız her birazcık olan her
birer Çubuk bu çubuklar birleşerek
size
oluşturuyor beğenmeniz oluşturuyor
baktığımızda mesela arkadaşının
şekillerde sonra bir anlamıyorsun değil
mi
bunlar ne ya böyle saçma sapan
Yaman Şimdi burada arkada gördüğünüz
şekiller sonra kalabilirim
benim lisedeyken
kendimi geliştirmek için kullandığım
tekniklerin resimleri lisedeyken
ben size hazırlık süreci Tabi bir
afallama dönem olduğu şey ikiye kadar
çok başarılıydım ama bize 2'den sonra
büyük macerası sonra derslerden soğuma
sonra ders çalışma süreci başladı O
süreçte çok sıkıldım
benden daha hizmeti olan kişiler beni
geçmeye başladı ve ben normalde bir
sınıftayken Bir de iken içe düştüm
psikolojik olarak da çok kötü bir
süreçti sonra bir gün bir bilgi
yarışması oldu o bilgi yarışmasında
birinci oldum birinciye cüzdan
veriyorlardı
ağzı deri cüzdan
başka bir arkadaşa da bir kitap
vermişler enerji ile alaka çocuğa dedim
ki değişir misin bu benim ilgimi çekti
biraz böyle baktım
olur değişir dedi İşine geldi çünkü
cüzdan pahalı hediye şey istemedim ki
tabii ya
ben o gece o kitabı bitirdim sonra
kitap bitirdikten sonra kendime
özgüvenim geldi çünkü kitapta diyor ki
bütün dünyayı boş verin
1 milyon ya milyonlarca taraftarın bir
stadyumda olduğunu düşünün ve hepsi
isminizi alması diyor işte Zaten zaten
Bunlar sizin de inceleyiniz
oyun üzerinize en büyük desteğimiz nedir
Ben ondan sonra kitabı gece bitirdim Ve
arkasından yine ders çalışmıyorum
Hatta babam kızıyor dut sevgiler o zaman
55 lira vermiştim
orada ben gittim Dedim ki ben Ah hafıza
eğitimi bi enerjiyi bitireyim hızlı
okumayı alayım Sonra duygusal zeka
ruhsal zeka vakti Bunlar da hoşuma gitti
sonra liderlikte duygusal zeka sonra
beden dili bu ara Ben akşamları ders
çalışıyor ben Bunlarla uğraşıyorum
herkes bacak Ne yapıyorsun sen ya otur
dersini çalışsana
bir dönem bittiğinde Eskiler bilir 30
Sayısal'ın vardı
120 puan yapıyordu yani Barajı zor
geçiyordum gece dönemde 15 gün kapandım
çünkü bütün teknikeri bitirdim oturdum
hızlı okuma ve hafıza teknikleriyle
Haziran'a kadar bir çift için kitapları
bitirdim
74-75 sayısına geldim yeter bana dedim
daha fazlasını gerek yok orada bıraktım
Sonra
sınav
sesi işte kazandım nereyi seçelim işte
Mühendislik Olsun olsun pilotluk olsun
tutuyor hepsini
düşündüm ben bunu yapmak istemiyorum
dedim Bir de tabii eğer bir şimdi olunca
ayarlayın peşinden koşmak istedim ama
kendini Bir Hayal Bulamadım ya Doktor
olmak istiyorum istemiyorum hadi sorma
bu konuda istemiyorum pilota istemiyorum
Ne olsam diye düşündüm Sonra tesadüf
karşıma böyle
bir gazetenin böyle mesleki tanıtım
simitleri vardı orada
fizyoterapistlik çıktı
baktım
Sonra İnternetten araştırdım Türkiye'de
Ortaokulda var tabi Şimdi yüze yakın
oldu herhalde
Sonra
Amerika'da en çok kazanan ikinci meslek
Ben bunu tercih ederim tabi çevremde hiç
kimse izin vermiyor puanı 8 puan altında
şunu öğrendim
Eğer bir şey gerçekten inanıyorsanız
oğlum peşinden koşacağız babamdan gizli
tercihleri verdim ondan sonra sınav
açıklandı işte aradım söyledim
çok fazla tebrik almadım Hatta amcam
Baytar olacağım falan diye sordu
kimsenin bir anladığı yok hatta bu
yapışan bir O zaman işte seni geçeceğim
geçeceğim diye bir kız vardı o da senin
doktorun yanına alacaksınız Affedersiniz
böyle Moral bozucu bir süreçle bile
tercih yaptım neden bolu'yu tercih ettim
bunun puanı 8 puan altında Ama her sene
30 kişi alıyordu
diğer okullar 92 alıyordu 62 şöyle
beğendim az olan yere gittim ama bir
adet tut Bolu'da deprem olmuştu mm
yılında Okulumuz yıkılmış bizimprefabrik
ve ben oraya gittim ben buradayım
kendimi
geliştirebilirim ben sonra işte bu
çubuklar Yavaş yavaş oynamaya başlıyorum
öğrenciyken sürekli şunu duyuyoruz çok
ayağa kırıyorsun hayalperestsin
yapamazsın Öyle mi
yaptık zihinsel engellilerle
Tiyatrosu zor yapamazsın dünyada işte
yapıyorlar ama işte elinden tutarak
çıkarıyorlar öyle mi dedim sahneye bu
arttırma Sen iyice akışlarında susarlar
seyirci güldüğünde dolarlar ve
inanamazsınız Dedim iki buçuk yıl sonra
yaptım iki buçuk uğraştım ama
tiyatro topluluğuna gittik dedi ki
ihtiyatla topluluğa girmek istiyoruz
bizim sınıfta Siz fizyoterapi sizin
işiniz var
gittik tiyatro topluluğu kurduk okulun
en çok kazandıran ve en büyük tiyatro
topluluğu
diğer topluluk yasadan sildik birçok
tiyatro oyunu ve birçok ünlü oyuncuyla
Yıldız Kenter L vesaire birçok oyuncu
Yalçın yüzden ve o zamandan tanıştık
rahmetli Turgut Özakman da söyleşiler
düzenledik ve Salih arkada zaten oyun
hepsini gördünüz gün
sonra meslek hayatı meslek hayatında da
yine bir varolma çabası
Tıp merkezindeyim diş hekiminin adı
yazıyor Dr o fizyoterapistin alıyor niye
Biz orada çalışmıyorum gideceğim bizde
bir meslek sahibi değilmiş işte hiçbir
yerde atıyor sizde de olmayacak falan
Ben dedim o zaman çalışmam
o zaman ve çekebilir şimdi kalamıyorum
Yok yok Sonra
adım yazıldı bu Herkesin dışına sonra
bütün Ada Tıp merkezlerinin içine
fizyoterapistler yazıldı varolma çabası
devam etti İşte bu
şekiller devam edecek
işte pilates yapıyorum niye pilates
yapıyorsun pilatesle ne işin var manuel
terfi eğitimleri alıyorum arkadaşlarım
İşte o zamanlar çok iyi para kazanıyor
fizyoterapistler Ev aldılar Aldılar ben
de onların harcadığı paranın iki katını
eğitimleri harcadım
şimdi maalesef Onlar hala aynı paraları
çalışırlarken hiç şu an çok farklı bir
yere getirdik olalım
manuel terapi Bu çok hoşuma gitti Ve ben
bunu dedim hani kimler yapar yurtdışında
kimleri yapıyordur araştırdım kendimi
zor kabul ettirdim beş yıl peşlerinde
dolaştım Amerika ise Amerika Brezilya
Brezilya ve en son Onların on yıl sonra
gösterdiği hedefe dört yıl sonra ulaştım
ulusal sonuca ve ünvanı alan ilk Türk
olarak orada
yer aldım Bu arada süren bitiyor 3-4
dakika var mı
Evet tamam yetmedi
bu daha sonra
bir kurum açmak istedim kurum açarken
dediler ki ya Zafer İşine gücüne bak
işte hastanede iyi çıkar iyi
kazanıyorsunuz şöyle böyle ama biz de
işte şöyle bir şey var biz hep geleceği
planlayıp geleceği görmek ile ilgili bir
çaba içerisindeyiz ve sürekli hayal
kurma işte ben diyor ki ben bu hastane
Yaptığım işten keyif almıyorum Ben böyle
çalışırsam mutsuz olacağım mutlu
olacağım bir iş yapmalıyım ip şu an
Türkiye'de 20 şubeye ulaşmış yurtdışında
şubeler açacak ve daha da şubeleri gelen
kendi kendine işleyen hocaları olan
yaklaşık yüz fizyoterapistin çalıştığı
bir yere dönüştü Adana'da ara sokaktan
açılan bir kurum ne demek ki eorik
anlattığım konuyu şimdi size böyle özet
geçerek anlatıyorum bir şekilde başara
biliyorsunuz ve tel teklifi dedim ya
çubuklar hepsinin bir sebebi var mesela
öğrenci kenti yaptığını uğraştım sosyal
projelerle uğraştım bu çubuklar ve ne
işe yaradığı üst düzey insanlarla rahat
konuşmam yeteneği kazandırdığı ve sosyal
becerilerini geliştirdi sosyal becerinin
gelişmesi İş hayatınızda size şunu
kazandırıyor yeni mezun olduğunda çok
iyi bir fizyoterapist değilim şu anda
iyi oldum iddiası yok ama
hastalarla muhabbet ediyordum sohbet
ediyordum ilgileniyordum onlarla empati
kuruyorum ve bir anda adım Zafer çok iyi
fizyoterapiste çıktı Ben bir ayda
Bu bir anda özel hastane çoğaldı Ben
dedim madem dedim bana İyi diyorlar ben
çalışayım
bu Ve şimdi de ilginç bir şey soracağım
şimdi burada hocayım diyorum Mustafa
soyacağım işte yüze yakın fizyoterapist
çalışıyor işte eğitimler veriyorum ben
okulun sondan birinci bitirdim
Bu enteresan değil mi bu çünkü keyif
almıyordum derslerden keyif almıyorum ve
son seneye kadar da çok ders çalışmadım
ama Serdar hocamız var bizi çekti dedi
ki bak çok zekisin akıllısın Ama ders
çalışmıyorsun dedi çalışmazsan seni
gebertirim dedi Aynen öyle dedi
bekliyorum dedi Ve o günden beri çok
çalışıyorum ama yetmedi yani okul anca
sondan birinci bitirebildim Çünkü ilk
başta notlar çok kötüydü be yıllarca
mesleği tanıtmak için bir şeyler yaptım
işte sürekli ücretsiz ve cebinden para
harcayarak fizyoterapisi nasıl tanıtırım
diye etkinliklerde bulundum yine tel
sehriye getiriyorum bu çubuklar var ya
orada on yıl boyunca Mesela şu an ben de
niye Muhittin abim dahil birçok kişiyle
tanıştım televizyon sektöründen ve Hoca
olduğum için de televizyona çıkmak
istemiyordum Yani öyle bir Çünkü
öğrencilerindeki kadın programda ne işi
var ve gerçekten de çıkmıyorum Bir gün
bir şey oldu yine bu mesleği tanıtmak
diye Amacım benim bir hedefiniz vardı en
son ana fikir Vereceğim son otuz saniye
bir dakika bitti
amacın neydi benim meslek
fizyoterapistlik çok iyi meslekler bunu
bu ülkede tanıtmak istiyorum Bunun için
bir sürü sayısız girişim dergiler
televizyon programları gazete
röportajları Dernek görevleri eylemler
Ankara'nın göbeğindeki 500 kişiyle
elemler yaptık vesaire Ama bu süreçte
tanıştığım bir sürü insan Biriktirdim
ve bir gün tüm camianın rahatsız olduğu
bir adamı televizyona çıkarttılar 40140
Ç
az önce bir doktorla sonra bir
fizyoterapistle Ama adam bizim yapıp
duruyor ve beni arıyorlar
Sen beni arıyorlar Ben de gelmem diyorum
Benim çıkmam diyorum hani ne işin var
kadın programda ya Zafer geldiler Bak bu
senin alın Peki bu araya mm nereden
biliyor İşte o yaptığım
organizasyonlarda tanıştığın kişilerden
birisi aradı beni Çünkü bile benim Hoca
olduğumu
yayına çıktım ve o günden sonra a olay
çok farklı bir yere Doğru doğru Ne oldu
hedefi neydi Biz Yo terapistliği
tanıtmak ve tabi birşey oldu Ve şimdi
kurduğumuz son Hayal bir televizyon
programı yapmak istedim bir sağlık
programı ama dedim bu böyle klasik
olmasın gece yayınlansın Tokio tadında
olsun işte
ünlü konuklar olsun ama biz böyle
muhabbet sohbet yapalım sonra da
işte bir tane uzman gelsin biz onunla
böyle yine konuyu sıkmadan anlatalım
diye bu hayal de yaklaşık 10 yıldır
vardı ve buraya gelmeden önce
gerçekleştirdik teşekkür ediyorum abone
ol